I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello! Hi, you guys.
我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正在为你们制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们将剖析《办公室》的一集，并提供只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。你好！嗨，大家好。
Welcome everyone for our breakdown of Search Committee Part 2. We've got a special guest in here with us today. We sure do. A tall drink of water called Rainn Wilson. Who do you have? Who's the special guest? It's you, Rainn. Oh, I'm a special guest star.
欢迎大家收看我们对《搜寻委员会》第2部分的解析。今天我们有一位特别嘉宾。确实如此。一位名叫雷恩·威尔森的“高个子帅哥”。你请了谁？特别嘉宾是谁？是你，雷恩。哦，我是特别客串明星。
You are. You guys, you know, I love the podcast. I've been on it before, but I tell you, sitting around this table with you with actual microphones and like looking into your eyes is really powerful. Like I've just missed you guys and just kind of seeing your bodies. That's what she said. But no, being in the same room with you guys is really cool. I agree.
你是。伙计们，你们知道，我喜欢这个播客。我以前来过，但我告诉你们，和你们坐在这张桌子旁，用真正的麦克风，看着你们的眼睛，感觉真的很震撼。就像我真的很想念你们，看着你们的身体。那是她说的。但说真的，和你们待在同一个房间里真的很酷。我同意。
It's so nice that we're able to do this now. It was 10 years we were in the same room together. Yeah. Every day, Monday through Friday. Every day. And it's been 10 years since the finale, since we shot the finale. Yes. That's amazing.
我们现在能这样做真是太好了。我们在一起待了10年。是的。每天，周一到周五。每天。距离大结局，距离我们拍摄大结局已经过去10年了。是的。太神奇了。
2013. Wow. Wow. Was it really? Yeah. Oh my gosh. That's nuts. That's nuts.
2013年。哇。哇。真的是吗？是的。天哪。太疯狂了。太疯狂了。
It's so great seeing you guys. I can't wait to catch up. Thanks for having me. Well, Rainn, we are in the final episode of season seven. Search committee part two. We've been discussing all the buzz around who would replace Michael Scott as manager. This was happening. There was lots of chatter on set and whatnot.
见到你们真是太好了。我迫不及待想叙叙旧了。谢谢你们邀请我。好吧，雷恩，我们正在进行第七季的最后一集。《搜寻委员会》第2部分。我们一直在讨论关于谁将接替迈克尔·斯科特担任经理的各种传闻。这确实发生了。片场内外有很多闲聊。
And a lot of chatter online when the episodes aired. This was the land of a thousand guest stars Ray Romano and Jim Carrey and Will Arnett and so many great folks popping up. What can you share with us about your thoughts during this transition of Steve leaving of us kind of having no decision made going into the summer? What do you remember? Yeah. That was, it was, it was a weird time.
当剧集播出时，网上也有很多讨论。那是千位客串明星的时代，雷·罗马诺、吉姆·凯瑞、威尔·阿奈特，还有这么多伟大的明星出现。在史蒂夫离开、我们在夏天到来之前还没有做出决定的这段过渡期，你能分享一下你的想法吗？你还记得什么？是的。那是一段奇怪的时光。
You know, the show was trying to find its footing post Steve and I just remember it being a really interesting time and I remember thinking like, because they talked to me like, well, maybe Dwight should be manager and how would that work? And, you know, I remember having long conversations with Paul about that because Paul was kind of steering the ship at that point. And honestly, like, I didn't even know if Dwight should be the manager. Like, it wasn't like I was, me, Rainn Wilson was like, well, I should be the manager and Dwight should be the manager.
你知道，剧组在史蒂夫离开后试图站稳脚跟，我只记得那是一段非常有趣的时光，我记得当时在想，因为他们和我谈过，也许德怀特应该担任经理，那会怎么运作？而且，你知道，我记得和保罗就此进行了长时间的交谈，因为保罗当时在掌舵。老实说，我甚至不知道德怀特是否应该担任经理。并不是说我，雷恩·威尔森，觉得“嗯，我应该成为经理，德怀特应该成为经理”。
I mean, I was intrigued by how that would work. And at the same time Dwight has always worked so well in opposition to something and in, you know, in collusion with something comedically, you know, has coming in from the outside, you know, and, and I think ultimately it really, I don't know if it would have succeeded to have Dwight the manager at that point because it, it stuck the landing so spoiler alert stuck the landing so well when he became manager at the very end of the show. Yeah. Yeah.
我的意思是，我对它将如何运作很感兴趣。与此同时，德怀特在喜剧上总是与某事对立，或者与某事勾结，你知道，从外部进入，而且，我认为最终，如果当时让德怀特担任经理，我不确定它是否会成功，因为它在剧集最后他成为经理时，结局处理得太好了，所以剧透预警，结局处理得太好了。是的。是的。
And there were a lot of talks. We talked about, you know, Catherine Tate and then James Spader and there were lots of other names that were being floated. I heard a rumor about James Gandolfini. Yes. Yes. I've got all the James Gandolfini dish when we get to the list. Yeah.
当时有很多讨论。我们谈到了凯瑟琳·塔特，然后是詹姆斯·斯派德，还有很多其他名字被提出来。我听到了关于詹姆斯·甘多菲尼的传闻。是的。是的。当我们列出名单时，我会把关于詹姆斯·甘多菲尼的所有内幕都告诉你。是的。
Okay. Jenna stumbled across some delicious nuggets. Oh, wow. Yeah. That wasn't almost happened. Wow. Yeah. That's incredible.
好的。珍娜偶然发现了一些美味的八卦。哦，哇。是的。那差点就发生了。哇。是的。太不可思议了。
That would have, that would have been, by the way, James Gandolfini, favorite movie? The Rocker. Yeah. Yes. I mean, did Jenna, I was like, do you think Rain knows that? Yep. So it was in the New York Times and I was like, okay, well, he just spouted some name of some dumb comedy that he liked, then I met him in person.
顺便问一下，詹姆斯·甘多菲尼最喜欢的电影是哪部？《摇滚青春》。是的。是的。我的意思是，珍娜，我在想，你觉得雷恩知道吗？是的。所以它在《纽约时报》上，我就想，好吧，他只是随口说了一个他喜欢的愚蠢喜剧的名字，然后我亲自见到了他。
I went and saw him in a play. Oh, God of Carnage? God of Carnage. Oh, I saw him in that too. Yeah. Incredible. It was a great ensemble. Marsha Gay Harden.
我去看他演的戏了。哦，天哪，《杀戮之神》？《杀戮之神》。哦，我也看了那部戏。是的。不可思议。那是一个很棒的剧团。玛莎·盖·哈登。
Marsha Gay Harden is amazing. Oh my gosh. And I knew Marsha Gay because we had gone to acting school together and I said hi to her and then James Gandolfini came around the corner. I'm not, I'm not making this up. And he came around the corner and he saw me, he turned beat red, no pun intended, and just stopped in his tracks and he was like, oh, no, wait, oh my God, oh, oh my God, oh God. I don't know what to say right now.
玛莎·盖·哈登太棒了。天哪。我认识玛莎·盖，因为我们一起上过表演学校，我跟她打了招呼，然后詹姆斯·甘多菲尼从拐角处走过来。我不是，我不是在编故事。他从拐角处走过来，看到了我，他脸涨得通红，不是双关语，他停下了脚步，他说，哦，不，等等，哦，天哪，哦，哦，天哪，哦，天哪。我现在不知道该说什么。
You are kidding. No. And he came up and he was like bowing, he's like, The Rocker, The Rocker. I have seen it like 12th, oh my God, The Rocker, oh my God, that movie, oh. And he just, it was incredible. And I was like, Mr. Gandolfini, I was just such a huge soprano span, I loved just all of his stuff. So that was pretty cool because, you know, seven people saw that movie when it came out
你在开玩笑吧。没有。他走过来，鞠躬说，《摇滚青春》，《摇滚青春》。我已经看了大概12遍了，哦，天哪，《摇滚青春》，哦，天哪，那部电影，哦。他就是，这太不可思议了。我说，甘多菲尼先生，我一直是《黑道家族》的超级粉丝，我喜欢他所有的作品。所以这很酷，因为，你知道，那部电影上映时只有七个人看过。
and I guess James Gandolfini was one of them. What a moment. That is something you'll hold forever. It really was. That was, that was a very special minute and a half of my life. Now, Rain, you're saying you're not sure that Dwight should have been manager, but we did get a taste of Dwight as manager and Dwight K. Shrut acting manager and it was a delicious dish.
我想詹姆斯·甘多菲尼是其中之一。真是个难忘的时刻。那是你永远会记住的事情。确实如此。那是我生命中非常特别的一分半钟。现在，雷恩，你说你不确定德怀特是否应该担任经理，但我们确实尝到了德怀特担任经理的滋味，德怀特·K·舒鲁特代理经理，那是一道美味的佳肴。
That was delicious. I loved that episode. That was super fun and it was such a crazy time. We're just that combination of like, we're trying to find our comedy legs and at the same time, figure out what other great, larger than life comedic presences to bring into the show and into the ensemble. And it's, it's a really tricky, delicate chemistry. So far I have been enjoying it quite a bit.
那很美味。我喜欢那一集。那超级有趣，那是一个如此疯狂的时代。我们只是那种组合，就像，我们试图找到我们的喜剧立足点，同时，找出还有什么其他伟大、超凡脱俗的喜剧存在可以带入剧中和剧组。这是一种非常棘手、微妙的化学反应。到目前为止，我一直很享受它。
Like when we saw James Spader come in, I hang on his every word. I just can't get enough of him. I remember hanging on his every word when he was literally there as a person. I remember his rehearsal. We had gotten sort of lazy in our blocking, you know, we were like, oh, I go up to reception and I stand here. I'm at the copier. I get it.
就像我们看到詹姆斯·斯派德进来时，我对他说的每一个字都洗耳恭听。我对他简直爱不释手。我记得当他本人真的在那里时，我对他说的每一个字都洗耳恭听。我记得他的排练。我们在走位上变得有点懒散，你知道，我们就像，哦，我走到接待处，我站在这里。我在复印机旁。我明白了。
I look over there and then our first day rehearsing with him. He had like a visual map in his brain. You could see he'd walk over. He'd say, I then I pick up my glasses, then I set my notebook down, then I take two steps. And he was going through this process. Yeah. I pick up my glasses on this line and that's when I'm going to put them on and I'm going to look that way.
我往那边看，然后我们和他排练的第一天。他脑子里有一张视觉地图。你可以看到他走过去。他说，我然后拿起我的眼镜，然后我放下我的笔记本，然后我走两步。他正在经历这个过程。是的。我在这一句台词拿起我的眼镜，那就是我要戴上它们的时候，我要往那边看。
Yeah. And then when we decided to do it again, he went back to a starting spot, but like in reverse like, these Martin date means everything. He like went through each step backwards. Yeah. It's amazing. His interview as Robert California in this episode was just brilliant. That was, you know, you can debate.
是的。然后当我们决定再做一次时，他回到了起始位置，但就像倒带一样，这些动作意味着一切。他就像倒着走完每一步。是的。太神奇了。他在这一集中作为罗伯特·加利福尼亚的面试简直太精彩了。那是，你知道，你可以争论。
Was Robert California right for the show? You know, you can debate that. I think he brought a lot of great stuff to the show and he's a stellar talent that I have loved for 30 years. But that interview was amazing. His job interview in this episode was absolutely incredible. It was. You're never selling something.
罗伯特·加利福尼亚适合这部剧吗？你知道，你可以争论这一点。我认为他为这部剧带来了很多伟大的东西，他是一位我喜欢了30年的杰出人才。但那次面试太棒了。他在这一集里的工作面试绝对不可思议。确实如此。你从来没有在推销什么。
You're never selling sex, right? Toby and Toby's like, yeah, it's so good. Well, we loved how you as Dwight interviewed yourself. Yeah. I actually think we should play it, Jenna. Okay. If you're not going to interview me, then I'll do it. Yes.
你从来没有在推销性，对吧？托比，托比说，是的，太好了。好吧，我们喜欢你作为德怀特面试自己的方式。是的。我其实觉得我们应该播放它，珍娜。好的。如果你不打算面试我，那我就自己来。是的。
What will be your first priority? I will have seven first priorities, safety, profits, fostering a community of self-reliance and entrepreneurship, listening, respect for human life, bolstering our public image and getting everyone home on time. Dwight, let me be frank. In an accident that no one can blame you for, an antique gun was discharged while you were acting manager. How are we ever to trust you again?
你的首要任务是什么？我会有七个首要任务：安全、利润、培养自力更生和创业的社区、倾听、尊重人类生命、提升我们的公众形象以及让每个人准时回家。德怀特，让我直说吧。在一次没人能责怪你的事故中，当你担任代理经理时，一把古董枪走火了。我们怎么还能信任你？
That's a great question. I am going to institute a strict no firearms policy for this office that extends to myself as well. Wow. All of my concerns are disappearing. Thank you, Dwight. Thank you. You'll be hearing from us shortly, Mr. Shrut.
这是一个很好的问题。我将在这个办公室实施严格的禁止枪支政策，这也适用于我自己。哇。我所有的担忧都消失了。谢谢你，德怀特。谢谢。我们很快会给你答复，舒鲁特先生。
And I think you're going to like the call you're going to receive. Oh, come on. I'm just happy that I got this meeting. It's so well written. When you got the script, did you just get so excited about getting to do that? A couple of things. So this script, I had two comedy situational comedy gems, the Jacques Souvenet interview with the burn victim and this self interview.
而且我想你会喜欢你接到的那个电话的。哦，得了吧。我只是很高兴我得到了这次会议。写得太好了。当你拿到剧本时，你是否因为能做这件事而感到非常兴奋？有几件事。所以这个剧本，我有两个情景喜剧的瑰宝，雅克·苏维内采访烧伤受害者和这次自我采访。
And I remember just being gleefully ecstatic at this possibility. I think the Jacques Souvenet, there is a, you know, if Dave Rogers is doing super sized episodes and longer episodes, I think there is a much longer, much funnier Jacques Souvenet extended scene because I remember that going on for a long time and us laughing and finding so much stuff. And they, because they have to chop everything down and it ended up being, you know, 47 seconds. But there's a couple minutes of really good stuff in there. And then taking a step back, I think one of the things I greatly appreciate about the
我记得当时对这种可能性感到欣喜若狂。我认为雅克·苏维内，有一个，你知道，如果戴夫·罗杰斯在做超大集和更长的剧集，我认为有一个更长、更有趣的雅克·苏维内扩展场景，因为我记得那持续了很长时间，我们笑得很开心，发现了这么多东西。而且他们，因为他们必须把一切都删减，最终变成了，你知道，47秒。但里面有几分钟非常好的东西。然后退一步说，我认为我非常欣赏的一件事是
show looking back on it now is there's a classic comedy element to the office that's often overlooked like physical comedy and kind of comedy setups that kind of come from almost like Comedia Del Arte or Vaudeville of like, how do we create a situation in which this little kind of nugget like the Jacques Souvenet burn victim interview can happen within the context of these characters that we know and love. I mean, it's, it's as old as sitcoms themselves, this idea. But the writers would consistently give me stuff like that, that was when I look back on the show, some of the stuff comedically that I savor the most was the amazing stuff
回顾这部剧，现在《办公室》有一个经常被忽视的经典喜剧元素，比如肢体喜剧和那种几乎来自意大利即兴喜剧或杂耍的喜剧设置，比如，我们如何创造一个情境，让这个小小的片段，比如雅克·苏维内烧伤受害者采访，可以在我们熟悉和喜爱的这些角色的背景下发生。我的意思是，这个想法和情景喜剧本身一样古老。但编剧们会不断给我这样的东西，当我回顾这部剧时，我在喜剧上最珍视的一些东西就是那些令人惊叹的东西
that gave Dwight, like Dwight fighting himself, you know, it's just, it's a brilliant, these are brilliant little setups. I don't know how else to, there are little stories within stories. It's a lotsy, you know, from Comedia Del Arte, it's a lotsy and there's two amazing ones in this. And yeah, it was just a, just a pleasure to be a part of. No, and it's, it's been so fun to rewatch. I think one of the things that keeps happening for me is I just appreciate you guys so much
给了德怀特，比如德怀特与自己战斗，你知道，这只是，这是一个天才，这些是天才的小设置。我不知道还能怎么说，它们是故事中的小故事。这是意大利即兴喜剧中的“拉齐”，这里面有两个很棒的。是的，能参与其中真是太荣幸了。不，而且，重温它真的很有趣。我认为对我来说不断发生的一件事是我非常欣赏你们
more like all the little nuances, all the choices people made, you just get to see it and sort of savor it. Yeah, I think getting distance from it and then rewatching it, you don't have any of the memories of what really happened when you were shooting it. So you're not attached to seeing a certain thing or a funny thing that you remember. Yeah. You're looking at a moment in amber and in a very different way, you know, you know, the Creed cold opening of manager and then tossing the keys to no one.
更多，就像所有的细微差别，所有人做出的选择，你只是能看到它并细细品味。是的，我认为与它保持距离然后重温它，你没有任何关于拍摄时真正发生了什么的记忆。所以你不会执着于看到某件特定的事情或你记得的有趣的事情。是的。你正在以一种非常不同的方式看着琥珀中的瞬间，你知道，你知道克里德作为经理的冷开场，然后把钥匙扔给没人。
Like it just, it's a beautiful little comedic tip of the hat to like everything that Creed does best as a character and as an actor and performer. And then they're writing to the actors strengths and know exactly how to get the best laughs on Creed. Braden. Yeah. We talked to Creed about his made up language and he said a little piece of backstory he had given himself, but he never told anyone is that he really thought maybe it would
就像它，它是一个美丽的、小小的喜剧致敬，致敬克里德作为一个角色和作为演员、表演者所做的一切最好的事情。然后他们根据演员的优势进行创作，并确切地知道如何从克里德身上获得最好的笑声。布雷登。是的。我们和克里德谈过他自创的语言，他说他给自己的一点背景故事，但他从未告诉任何人，他真的认为也许有一天会
be revealed someday that Creed was an alien. So he thought his made up language should sound like an alien. That is perfect. That is intentional how we did it. I pitched, I rarely pitched episode ideas. I pitched a Creed episode that was 100% Creed and they didn't go for it. It would have been way to experiment. What was the premise?
揭示克里德是个外星人。所以他认为他自创的语言应该听起来像外星人。这太完美了。我们这样做是故意的。我提议，我很少提议剧集创意。我提议了一集100%是克里德的剧集，但他们没采纳。那会太实验性了。前提是什么？
The premise was they're just doing regular thing and there's Pam and Jim and it's the copy machine and something, you know, Michael comes in and blah, blah, blah, just and we think it's just a normal episode and then it kind of catches Creed and then Creed looks at the camera and he just gestures come here and they grabs his stuff and goes out the door and he keeps gesturing to the camera and gets the camera and puts it in his car. He's like, come with me. You need to see something. And then we do 22 minute Odyssey into the life of Creed.
前提是他们只是在做常规的事情，有帕姆和吉姆，那是复印机，还有什么，你知道，迈克尔进来了，等等等等，只是，我们认为这只是普通的一集，然后它有点抓住了克里德，然后克里德看着镜头，他只是示意过来，他抓起他的东西走出门口，他继续向镜头示意，并让摄像机跟着他，把它放进他的车里。他说，跟我来。你需要看点东西。然后我们进行了22分钟进入克里德生活的奥德赛。
I would have loved that. So it just goes like deep. Like he's living in a warehouse and there's like dogfights down there and like he's got a whole other business that he's doing. Like he takes to his home and they're like daddy and he's got all these children and like, you know, just like this, like all of the stuff that you are wondering about Creed and just like layers and layers of backstory and, and the whole episode, I was like, there's no B story.
我会喜欢那个的。所以它就像深入挖掘。就像他住在仓库里，下面有斗狗，就像他还有另一项生意。就像他带回家，他们说爸爸，他有所有这些孩子，就像，你知道，就像这个，就像所有你对克里德感到好奇的事情，就像一层又一层的背景故事，而且，整集，我说，没有副线。
It's just following Creed around, you know, it goes into some ratty neighborhoods and maybe he's dealing drugs or whatever. Like it gets just really weird. And then he's Santa at the mall. Yeah, yeah, yeah. How do we end here? And they were like, no, no, that could have been our whole season 10. Yeah.
只是跟着克里德到处走，你知道，它进入了一些破烂的社区，也许他在贩毒什么的。就像它变得真的很奇怪。然后他在商场里扮演圣诞老人。是的，是的，是的。我们怎么在这里结束？他们说，不，不，那可能是我们的整个第10季。是的。
Just every episode, just follow someone out the door into their life. Yeah, yeah. Fascinating. Yeah. Well, Rain, thank you for discussing the office with us, but you're also here to discuss something else. Your amazing book. Scrubs.
每一集，只是跟着某人走出门口进入他们的生活。是的，是的。太迷人了。是的。好吧，雷恩，谢谢你和我们讨论《办公室》，但你来这里也是为了讨论别的事情。你那本了不起的书。《实习医生风云》。
Yes. If you'd like. Yes. Have you been? Donald Faison and Zach Breff are waiting right outside. Okay. Guys, come here. Perfect.
是的。如果你愿意的话。是的。你怎么样？唐纳德·法森和扎克·布拉夫就在外面等着。好的。伙计们，过来。完美。
Your book that just came out this week, Soul Boom, Why We Need a Spiritual Revolution. Yeah. Soul and I got advanced copies because we knew someone. Lucky you. Yeah. I know. We got the hookup. Yes, lucky us because it's fantastic.
你这周刚出的书，《灵魂繁荣：为什么我们需要一场精神革命》。是的。灵魂和我拿到了预印本，因为我们认识人。幸运的你。是的。我知道。我们有门路。是的，我们很幸运，因为它太棒了。
It's so great. I mean, I texted you last night. I was so moved by this book and I can't wait to talk to you about it. Great. In the book, you lay out a plan for something that you are calling a spiritual revolution. And in the second chapter of the book, you go into great detail as to why we need this, why the world needs this. So can you tell us why did you want to write this book?
太棒了。我的意思是，我昨晚给你发了短信。我被这本书深深打动了，我迫不及待想和你谈谈。太棒了。在书中，你为某种你称之为精神革命的东西制定了一个计划。在书的第二章中，你详细说明了为什么我们需要这个，为什么世界需要这个。所以你能告诉我们你为什么要写这本书吗？
Well, thanks. This is a topic and a theme, a series of ideas that I have been thinking about for a very, very long time, studying and reading about and perusing and pondering. Basically, I think that I'm a big student of spirituality and thinker about it and I actively practice it in my life on a daily basis. I think that what humanity needs most right now is a spiritual revolution. I think that the way that things are broken in the world, they're broken for very specific reasons that we have lost touch with our essential humanity.
好吧，谢谢。这是一个主题，一个系列的想法，我已经思考了很长很长时间，研究、阅读、细读和思考。基本上，我认为我是一个伟大的灵性学生和思考者，我在日常生活中积极实践它。我认为人类现在最需要的是一场精神革命。我认为世界上的事情之所以破碎，是因为非常具体的原因，我们已经失去了与我们本质人性的联系。
And when I say humanity, I'm talking about that soul part of ourselves, that the ancient wise spiritual aspects of who we are, the divine that is within us, that emulates what is holy and divine in the universe, that our compassion and our courage and our honesty and our love as the great spiritual leaders of the world, from Jesus and Muhammad and the Buddha to Martin Luther King and the Dalai Lama, like all of these great spiritual teachers lead with that, same sense. And the book is entirely there. It doesn't give any answers per se, but simply to spark a discussion, a greater conversation
当我提到人性时，我指的是我们灵魂的那一部分，我们身上古老而智慧的精神层面，我们内在的神性，它模仿了宇宙中神圣和神圣的东西，我们的同情心、勇气、诚实和爱，正如世界上伟大的精神领袖，从耶稣、穆罕默德和佛陀到马丁·路德·金和达赖喇嘛，所有这些伟大的精神导师都以同样的感官引领。这本书完全在那里。它本身没有给出任何答案，只是为了引发讨论，一场更大的对话
about how can we bring a spiritual perspective far deeper into what we do both on an individual level, but also on a societal level. And I think that's the piece that's often missing. And I'll just wrap up by saying that I talk about the twofold moral path, the twofold spiritual path that we all walk. So we all walk a path where, and I compare it to two great 70s television shows because I try and bring a little humor into it, which is, which is, you're such a Trekkie to total nerd.
关于我们如何将精神视角更深入地带入我们所做的事情，无论是在个人层面，还是在社会层面。我认为这是经常缺失的部分。我最后要说的是，我谈到了双重道德道路，我们所有人走的双重精神道路。所以我们所有人都在走一条路，我把它比作两部伟大的70年代电视节目，因为我试图在其中加入一点幽默，也就是，也就是，你真是个星际迷航迷，彻头彻尾的书呆子。
Yes. The first chapter was very lost on me because it was very science fiction. Oh, I loved it. And then you brought back Star Wars at the end and I was like, oh, rain, you're checking all my boxes. But I loved the show Kung Fu from the 70s and I loved Star Trek. And Kung Fu, I see as a metaphor for the personal spiritual path because Kwai Chiang can't, people Google it.
是的。第一章对我来说很迷茫，因为它是非常科幻的。哦，我喜欢它。然后你在最后带回了《星球大战》，我就想，哦，雷恩，你满足了我所有的要求。但我喜欢70年代的节目《功夫》，我喜欢《星际迷航》。《功夫》，我把它看作个人精神道路的隐喻，因为葵昌，人们去谷歌一下。
I'm not going to explain the whole show, but it's basically a Chinese monk wandering through racist, mean, old Western America. That's what's going on. And so this Chinese Shaolin monk is trying to navigate a really difficult world filled with racist, greedy, selfish, aggressive people and bring his spiritual wisdom to bear as he goes on his quest. And this is what we are all doing in the world. We're trying to be better people.
我不会解释整个节目，但它基本上是一个中国僧侣在种族主义、刻薄、古老的西方美国流浪。这就是正在发生的事情。所以这个中国少林僧侣正试图在一个充满种族主义、贪婪、自私、好斗的人的非常困难的世界中航行，并在他追求的过程中发挥他的精神智慧。这就是我们所有人正在世界上做的事情。我们正在努力成为更好的人。
We're trying to grow our spiritual qualities. We're trying to live with more love. We're trying to, you know, be of service to our families. And this is the journey that we're on, whether we're a student or at work or at home with our kids or whatever it is that we're doing. So that's part one. And then part two is we also need to think about spirituality on a more global level. And we often lose track of that where humanity as a species, all seven billion of us on this
我们正在努力增长我们的精神品质。我们正在努力带着更多的爱生活。我们正在努力，你知道，为我们的家庭服务。这就是我们正在进行的旅程，无论我们是学生，还是在工作，还是在家里和孩子们在一起，或者无论我们在做什么。所以这是第一部分。然后第二部分是我们还需要在更全球的层面上思考灵性。我们经常忘记这一点，人类作为一个物种，我们所有70亿人
planet need to think about the spiritual tools that we can use to further the maturity and spiritual wisdom and growth on this planet. And that's what we really need and what we've lost sight of right now in these really divisive, angry times that are, because all of essentially all of the systems that work that are at work in the world today, the economic systems, the political systems, etc. are based on the worst of humanity. They're based on aggressiveness, contest, conflict, one-upsmanship, individualization, individualism.
在这个星球上需要思考我们可以用来促进这个星球的成熟、精神智慧和成长的精神工具。这就是我们真正需要的，也是我们在这些非常分裂、愤怒的时代所忽视的，因为本质上，当今世界上运作的所有系统，经济系统、政治系统等，都是基于人类最坏的一面。它们基于好斗、竞争、冲突、争强好胜、个人化、个人主义。
And we need to completely, the revolution is completely re-imagine how we do pretty much everything to base it on love, compassion, community, and mutual respect. Now that sounds very airy-fairy, hippy-dippy, pie-in-the-sky, naive, and I imagine there's been some high roles out there in the podcast listening world, but it really, it's a discussion we need to be having because the current systems and the way that they're laid out just don't work. So I think the thing that I really grabbed onto with the book is this distinction between the personal spiritual journey and the collective, the responsibility to the collective, because
我们需要彻底地，这场革命是彻底重新构想我们如何做几乎所有事情，以爱、同情、社区和相互尊重为基础。现在这听起来非常虚无缥缈、嬉皮士、异想天开、天真，我想在播客听众世界里已经有一些翻白眼了，但这确实是我们必须进行的讨论，因为当前的系统和它们的布局方式就是行不通。所以我认为我真正抓住这本书的一点是个人精神旅程与集体之间的区别，对集体的责任，因为
I think there are a lot of people out there who take on that personal spiritual journey of personal prayer, of meditation, yoga practice, walking in nature, working on their own personal qualities of patience, tolerance, you know, all of these things to help us get through our life. But I really loved how much you discussed the moral responsibility as a human being to investing in the collective spiritual journey. Yeah. Really well said.
我认为外面有很多人承担起个人祈祷、冥想、瑜伽练习、在大自然中行走、努力提高自己耐心、宽容等个人品质的个人精神旅程，以帮助我们度过生活。但我真的很喜欢你讨论作为一个人对投资集体精神旅程的道德责任。是的。说得真好。
Wow. That was great. Well, I read the book. I know you did. That's very clear. Yeah. But you also summarized it perfectly. That was really, really, really well said.
哇。那太棒了。好吧，我读了这本书。我知道你读了。这很清楚。是的。但你也完美地总结了它。那真的，真的，真的说得很好。
And one of the things you talk about in the book, you talk a lot about religion. Something I want everybody to know is that I'm very emotional right now because listening to you, Rain, this is, I just, this is you, you know, when you were talking just now, this is the man that I know, this is the man I've come to when I'm having hard times. And what excited me so much about your book is that I feel that this voice that I know you so well personally is going to be out in the world. And it is beautiful. One of the things.
而且你在书中谈到的一件事，你谈了很多关于宗教的问题。我想让每个人都知道的一件事是，我现在非常激动，因为听着你，雷恩，这，我只是，这就是你，你知道，当你刚才说话时，这就是我认识的那个男人，这就是我在困难时期会找的那个男人。你书中最让我兴奋的是，我觉得我如此了解的这个声音将出现在世界上。而且它很美。其中一件事。
For those of you who can't see it, Jenna and I are tearing up right now. We are. We truly are. We are. We are. This, you're just a beautiful person, Rain, and I just love you so much. So one of the things that the book makes clear is how you have studied so many various religions. And I know this about you.
对于那些看不到的人，珍娜和我现在都在流泪。我们是。我们确实是。我们是。我们是。这，你只是一个美丽的人，雷恩，我真的很爱你。所以这本书明确的一点是你研究了多少种不同的宗教。我了解你这一点。
You have traveled to numerous religious sites around the world. You have a dedication to faith and spirituality that is so clear. When you describe your pilgrimage to the holy Baha'i site is just absolutely beautiful. Yeah. I thought it was really moving. All of the study you've done, I found humbling. I'm emotional too, guys. I found it humbling just your heart for service and your heart for wanting to understand why
你曾前往世界各地众多的宗教场所。你对信仰和灵性的奉献是如此清晰。当你描述你前往巴哈伊圣地的朝圣之旅时，简直太美了。是的。我觉得它真的很感人。你所做的所有研究，我觉得很谦卑。我也很激动，伙计们。我发现仅仅是你为服务的心，你想要理解为什么的心，让我感到谦卑
people walk the path they walk and your compassion. You know, we've joked for a long time about you being the tall curmudgeon on set. But like Jenna said so eloquently, your heart and soul, your soul is in this book. I loved also Rain, your personal stories. I loved your story about your dad. My father also passed away. And the things you had to juggle on the day that he passed. Yeah.
人们走他们走的路，还有你的同情心。你知道，我们开玩笑说你是片场的高个子老顽固很久了。但就像珍娜说得那么雄辩，你的心和灵魂，你的灵魂就在这本书里。雷恩，我也很喜欢你的个人故事。我喜欢你关于你父亲的故事。我父亲也去世了。以及他在去世那天你不得不处理的事情。是的。
And I tell the story in the book for the listeners about when my dad died two and a half years ago now, during the pandemic, he died of heart disease during the pandemic, getting heart surgery, open heart surgery. But he lived in a little town, Wenatchee, Washington. And I'm a member of the Baha'i Faith, and in the Baha'i rituals and rites, just like in many other religions, you prepare the body for burial. So you wash the body and wrap it in linen and say a prayer and prepare it. But when you say you, you mean you personally, family members of the deceased.
我在书中为听众讲述了关于我父亲在两年半前去世的故事，在疫情期间，他在疫情期间死于心脏病，进行心脏手术，开胸手术。但他住在一个小镇，华盛顿州韦纳奇。我是巴哈伊信仰的成员，在巴哈伊的仪式和礼仪中，就像在许多其他宗教中一样，你准备尸体进行埋葬。所以你清洗尸体并用亚麻布包裹它，祈祷并准备它。但当你说是你时，你的意思是你们亲自，死者的家庭成员。
Yeah. It doesn't have to be family members, but we really wanted to do it. I wanted to be part of that, to experience that. And it's incredibly powerful to be, you know, frankly washing the body of someone that, you know, that raised you and that you've known for 79 years. But there was no bowl at the funeral home. You needed a bowl for water. For water to wash it.
是的。不一定是家庭成员，但我们真的很想这样做。我想成为其中的一部分，去体验它。而且，坦率地说，清洗一个你知道的、抚养你长大并且你已经认识了79年的人的尸体，是非常强大的。但殡仪馆里没有碗。你需要一个碗来装水。用来清洗的水。
And the guy was like, I've got a tea kettle you could use, or here's a styrofoam bowl to put the water in. From like takeout food or something. So it was, and we were up against the wire because we were supposed to do this ritual. And then get over to the burial and we had like 30 or 40 people coming. So I ran to the target. It was in the middle of a heat wave looking for a bowl to have water in an appropriate bowl to wash my dead father's body.
那个人说，我有一个茶壶你可以用，或者这里有一个泡沫塑料碗可以放水。来自外卖食品什么的。所以它是，而且我们时间紧迫，因为我们必须做这个仪式。然后去埋葬，我们有30或40人要来。所以我跑去塔吉特百货。那是在热浪中，寻找一个碗来装水，一个合适的碗来清洗我死去的父亲的尸体。
So I use that as kind of a, a touch point for a conversation about death. And I also use the book as an opportunity to, to dig into some of life's biggest, most profound questions in what I hope is a fun and sightful kind of goofy upside down way like death, consciousness, God, you know, the biggest questions of humanity. And I wanted to kind of put it through a rain Wilson lens. So that story was the way to get in. It was fantastic. I, I shared part of that chapter with my daughter and in particular rain.
所以我用它作为关于死亡的对话的切入点。我还利用这本书的机会，以我希望是一种有趣、深刻、有点古怪、颠倒的方式深入探讨一些人生中最宏大、最深刻的问题，比如死亡、意识、上帝，你知道，人类最大的问题。我想通过雷恩·威尔森的视角来审视它。所以那个故事是切入点。这太棒了。我，我与我的女儿分享了那一章的一部分，特别是雷恩。
One thing I learned about you in this book that I didn't know is how much you love quotes. You quote a lot of amazing people in this book. And I was going to tell you one of the quotes I love that I always think of when I meet people is it's from the chapter of Luke in the New Testament. It's part of a bigger verse, but the part that always sticks with me is the part that says out of the abundance of the heart, the mouth speaks. And I think about that when I hear people talk, like, what is their heart full of? What are they sharing about?
我在书中了解到的关于你的一件事是我不知道的，那就是你有多喜欢名言。你在书中引用了很多了不起的人的话。我本来想告诉你我喜欢的一句名言，每当我见到人时我都会想到它，它来自新约路加福音那一章。它是更大经文的一部分，但我一直记得的部分是说“心里所充满的，口里就说出来”。每当我听到人们说话时，我都会想到这一点，他们的心充满了什么？他们在分享什么？
What are they passionate about? And it's just something that sticks with me throughout life. That's beautiful. I wish I would have used that in my book. I wonder if I can get it in the next edition. You know, I do want to say this is a very easy read. I know we're talking about big, like heavy subjects, but you did write a book about big, heavy subjects and it's very entertaining.
他们对什么充满热情？这只是我一生中一直坚持的东西。那太美了。我真希望我在书中用了它。不知道我能不能在下一版中把它加进去。你知道，我确实想说这是一本非常容易读的书。我知道我们在谈论宏大、沉重的主题，但你确实写了一本关于宏大、沉重主题的书，而且它非常有趣。
I hope it's funny. And it clips along. It is. It's funny. It's relatable. You hear your personality and your sense of humor. And at the same time, you want to be a better person. I particularly appreciated your section titled Yo Atheists and Why I'm Not an Atheist.
我希望它很有趣。而且它节奏很快。确实。它很有趣。它很贴近生活。你能听到你的个性和幽默感。与此同时，你想成为一个更好的人。我特别欣赏你标题为“嘿，无神论者，以及为什么我不是无神论者”的部分。
And I really liked this because you are so interested in the arguments and beliefs of people who are very different from you. And you really show how to have a loving discourse with people who think differently. I loved your argument for why God exists, but I also loved your respect for science. I just thought that is one of the things in the book where whatever your current faith is, if you're a nunner, like you said, a lot of young people are checking the box, none of the above. Or if you are in an established faith or religion, this book respects you on every level, even
我真的很喜欢这个，因为你对与你非常不同的人的论点和信仰非常感兴趣。你真的展示了如何与想法不同的人进行充满爱的对话。我喜欢你关于上帝为什么存在的论点，但我也喜欢你对科学的尊重。我只是觉得这是书中其中一件事，无论你目前的信仰是什么，如果你是一个“无神论者”，就像你说的，很多年轻人勾选了“以上皆非”的框。或者如果你处于一种既定的信仰或宗教中，这本书在各个层面上都尊重你，即使
if you are an atheist, the respect is there. So Rain, in chapter eight, you say, hey kids, let's build the perfect religion. Your first sentence is seriously another chapter on religion, you're killing me with this. But you would, at this point, you would explore it so many and you're like, what is the one that will bring us all together? Yeah. And it was really great because you lay out all of the best parts of every religion, the things they have in common, and then you propose a new religion, which you call Soul
如果你是无神论者，尊重也在那里。所以雷恩，在第八章，你说，嘿孩子们，让我们建立完美的宗教。你的第一句话是“严肃点，又一章关于宗教，你快把我逼疯了”。但你会，在这一点上，你会探索这么多，你就像，哪一个是能把我们所有人聚集在一起的？是的。这真的很好，因为你列出了每个宗教中最好的部分，它们共同的东西，然后你提出了一个新的宗教，你称之为灵魂
Boom. Yeah. TM. Trademark. Trademark. He actually typed that in the book, TM. It's very clear in the book that you aren't really starting a new religion. Exactly.
繁荣。是的。TM。商标。商标。他实际上在书中打了那个，TM。书中很清楚你并不是真的在开始一个新的宗教。正是如此。
Rain, you were more just wanting to start a conversation about spirituality and just everyone's own journey. Well, I do want to say I did really like the sound of this religion. You mentioned it's very hard to get a new religion off the ground. You need a religious leader, you know, all this kind of stuff. Yeah, which is not going to be me. Yeah. I know.
雷恩，你更多只是想开始一场关于灵性的对话，以及每个人自己的旅程。好吧，我确实想说我真的很喜欢这个宗教的名字。你提到让一个新的宗教起步非常困难。你需要一个宗教领袖，你知道，所有这些东西。是的，那不会是我。是的。我知道。
Maybe Creed. I have a pitch for you. Okay. Go ahead. Okay. When I was in college, I went to see a psychic and to be fair, I was asking if I was going to marry this boy that I had a crush on. That was my motivation.
也许是克里德。我有一个提议给你。好的。继续。好的。我在大学时，去看了一个灵媒，公平地说，我当时在问我是否会嫁给我暗恋的那个男孩。那是我的动机。
The answer was no. Wow. He did not love me. He was not going to marry me. Okay. Was it a woman? It was a woman. Okay.
答案是否定的。哇。他不爱我。他不会娶我。好的。是个女人吗？是个女人。好的。
How did she know? I mean, I don't know, but she was right. Oh, okay. He didn't love me. He loved three other girls at the same time as me. He was one of those. Okay. Okay.
她怎么知道的？我的意思是，我不知道，但她是正确的。哦，好的。他不爱我。他同时爱着除了我之外的另外三个女孩。他是那种人。好的。好的。
So whatever. She said, cut him loose. It's not going to work out. Great. He loved Betsy Schnauzheiser. He loved everybody else. Teresa Von Vilner. He had a lot of love in his heart.
所以随便吧。她说，甩了他。这不会成功的。太棒了。他爱贝琪·施瑙泽。他爱所有其他人。特蕾莎·冯·维尔纳。他心里有很多爱。
He did. And in his pants. So then I said, well, am I going to be successful in life? You know, I'm studying. I'm a theater major. I want to be a successful actress. You're hitting her with the big questions. I did.
他确实有。而且在他的裤子里。所以我说，好吧，我会在生活中成功吗？你知道，我在学习。我是戏剧专业的。我想成为一名成功的女演员。你用大问题打击她。我做了。
I mean, you know, the only psychic I ever saw. And she said, you're going to be very famous one day, but not for the reasons you think. She said, you're going to be famous in the area of religion. You are going to be a famous religious leader. Whoa. Do you want to run Soul Boom? That's what I'm saying. Is this your pitch?
我的意思是，你知道，我见过的唯一一个灵媒。她说，你有一天会非常出名，但不是因为你认为的原因。她说，你会在宗教领域出名。你将成为一位著名的宗教领袖。哇。你想经营灵魂繁荣吗？这就是我说的。这是你的提议吗？
Maybe it's all coming together. I love it. I'm a hundred percent behind that. Where do I start? And you know what? You need another project. You're just saying to me, I want to take something really big on. Yeah.
也许一切都汇聚在一起了。我喜欢它。我百分之百支持那个。我从哪里开始？而且你知道吗？你需要另一个项目。你只是在对我说，我想承担一些非常大的事情。是的。
Yeah. Yeah. Perfect. What do I need to do? What do we need to do? Well, we need to get you. We need to get you some kind of office or, you know, we're going to start with an office worship center, maybe an office, an outfit, you know, we need to get someone to design,
是的。是的。完美。我需要做什么？我们需要做什么？好吧，我们需要让你。我们需要给你某种办公室，或者，你知道，我们将从一个办公室礼拜中心开始，也许是一个办公室，一套装备，你知道，我们需要找人设计，
you know, you need to look that you don't want, you know, no clergy. You don't want any clergy outfits. You said no funny hats. No funny hats. Yeah. No. Yeah. I don't know.
你知道，你需要看起来你不想，你知道，没有神职人员。你不需要任何神职人员的服装。你说没有滑稽的帽子。没有滑稽的帽子。是的。不。是的。我不知道。
We'll put our heads together. Let's figure this out. Okay. I love it. Well, I don't know. Maybe we'll make this moment's prediction come true. I did say that one of the components of building a perfect religion is no clergy, but I'm willing to reverse that.
我们会聚在一起。让我们弄清楚这一点。好的。我喜欢它。好吧，我不知道。也许我们会让这个时刻的预言成真。我确实说过建立完美宗教的组成部分之一是没有神职人员，但我愿意推翻这一点。
Really? Yeah. This was a very quick reversal. Yeah. That felt like an important tenant of your religion and you are backtracking quickly. I feel like there's like five people that could do it like you and Oprah and I don't even know who else. Creed.
真的吗？是的。这是一个非常快速的逆转。是的。这感觉像是你宗教的一个重要原则，而你正在迅速倒退。我觉得有五个人可以做到，比如你和奥普拉，我甚至不知道还有谁。克里德。
So maybe Creed. Yeah. Wow. Creed could run security. I love it. Guys, please read the book and let us know if you think I should start the soul boom religion. Well Rain, thank you for coming in today. We also want to mention one other thing.
所以也许是克里德。是的。哇。克里德可以负责安保。我喜欢它。伙计们，请读这本书，让我们知道你是否认为我应该开始灵魂繁荣宗教。好吧，雷恩，谢谢你今天过来。我们还想提另一件事。
So soul boom, why we need a spiritual revolution on sale now and then in May, you've got a show coming out on Peacock. May 20th. That's right. The geography of bliss. We're talking about dream jobs. I flew around the world looking for happiness. How can we find clues to happiness, fulfillment, meaning, joy from other cultures around the
所以灵魂繁荣，为什么我们需要一场精神革命，现在发售，然后在五月，你有一个节目要在孔雀台播出。5月20日。没错。《幸福的地理学》。我们在谈论梦想工作。我飞遍世界寻找幸福。我们如何从世界各地的其他文化中找到幸福、成就感、意义、快乐的线索？
world? We got to go to Iceland, Thailand, Ghana, West Africa, Bulgaria, and we did an episode right here in Los Angeles as well. Super fun and interesting and I call it like it's Anthony Bourdain, but instead of food, it's joy. Oh, I can't wait to watch it. It's a lot of fun. It's quirky.
我们去了冰岛、泰国、加纳、西非、保加利亚，我们也在洛杉矶做了一集。超级有趣和有趣，我称之为就像安东尼·波登，但不是食物，而是快乐。哦，我迫不及待想看了。这很有趣。它很古怪。
It's funny, but it also gets a little profound here and there. That sounds like you. Yeah. Maybe. Well, you guys, check out Rain's new book, Soul Boom, and we just love you so much. Thanks for being here today. Rain. I love you, Office Ladies.
它很有趣，但它也在这里和那里变得有点深刻。这听起来像你。是的。也许。好吧，伙计们，看看雷恩的新书，《灵魂繁荣》，我们真的很爱你。谢谢你今天在这里。雷恩。我爱你，《办公室》女士们。
Thanks for bringing me on your show. We'll be back to break down the rest of Search Committee Part 2. Well, it's time to break down the rest of this episode, Search Party Part 2. Search Committee. Thank you. Search Committee. Good to know what episode we're doing. Good start.
谢谢你们邀请我上你们的节目。我们会回来解析《搜寻委员会》第2部分的其余部分。好吧，是时候解析这一集的其余部分了，《搜寻派对》第2部分。搜寻委员会。谢谢。搜寻委员会。很高兴知道我们在做哪一集。好的开始。
All right. Well. Well, Joe is going to enter with a new set of dogs, actually sort of one of each dog now. Yeah. Yeah. She hands off her bags and her dogs to Gabe and she starts chatting with Jim about this morning's episode of Howard Stern.
好的。嗯。乔要带着新的一批狗进来了，实际上现在每种狗都有一只。是的。是的。她把包和狗交给盖博，然后开始和吉姆聊起今天早上的《霍华德·斯特恩秀》。
You know, he's great, but really, she feels like it's Robin. Robin is the highlight, right? But it's Howard's show. I love when Joe makes small talk. You never know what it's going to be about and I'm fascinated by her and her life. For me, the spin-off would have been Joe. Yeah. Where is Joe?
你知道，他很棒，但说真的，她觉得罗宾才是亮点，对吧？但这毕竟是霍华德的节目。我喜欢乔闲聊的时候。你永远不知道她会聊什么，我对她和她的生活很着迷。对我来说，衍生剧的主角应该是乔。是的。乔去哪了？
But Joe's personal life. I don't need to see her at work, only when she comes to Dunder Mifflin. Okay. All right. You know, like we're aside. Now, what is she doing outside of work? Yeah. That's the show I want to see.
但乔的私生活。我不需要看她在工作，除非是她来到邓德·米夫林的时候。好吧。好的。你知道，就像我们撇开工作不谈。现在，她在工作之外做什么？是的。那才是我想要看的节目。
In Florida. Yeah. Well, she's going to notice Daryl's resume is on the top of the pile and she's really happy to see, you know, someone she knows, someone in-house. But why is it four pages long? Yeah. And she reads part of his resume and she looks at him and says, you coordinated and implemented receipt, storage and delivery of over 2.5 billion units of inventory, 2.5 billion Daryl, 2.5
在佛罗里达。是的。嗯，她会注意到达里尔的简历就在那一叠的最上面，她很高兴看到，你知道，一个她认识的人，一个内部员工。但为什么简历有四页长？是的。她读了他简历的一部分，看着他说，你协调并实施了超过25亿单位库存的接收、存储和交付，25亿，达里尔，25亿
billion units of what? And Daryl says, paper material, like pieces of paper. Yeah. Lady, I was curious about paper, about resumes and how often do we lie on our resumes? Have you ever lied on a resume? No, but I have definitely added a flourish and special skills. As we've talked about, you know, I mean, I wouldn't normally put water skiing, but I have.
25亿单位的什么？达里尔说，纸质材料，就像纸片一样。是的。女士，我对纸张、简历以及我们在简历上撒谎的频率感到好奇。你在简历上撒过谎吗？没有，但我肯定加了一些修饰和特殊技能。正如我们谈到的，你知道，我的意思是，我通常不会写滑水，但我写过。
I don't think anyone thinks what I can do on a water ski is special. So, okay, this led me to an article on CNBC.com from December of 2022. It said, over 55% of people admit to lying on their resume at least once. And according to the survey done by Standout CV, they surveyed Americans 18 years and older and this is what they found out. The number of Google searches about how to fake a resume was up 48% in 2022, specifically related to faking a job reference was up 52%. You can Google that?
我不认为有人会觉得我在滑水板上的表现有什么特别的。所以，好吧，这让我找到了CNBC.com上2022年12月的一篇文章。文章说，超过55%的人承认在简历上至少撒过一次谎。根据Standout CV的一项调查，他们调查了18岁及以上的美国人，这就是他们的发现。2022年，关于如何伪造简历的谷歌搜索量上升了48%，特别是关于伪造工作推荐信的搜索量上升了52%。这也能谷歌到？
Y'all were Googling how to fake your resume. So this led me to this. What were people lying about? Here are the eight most common resume lies, according to Standout CV, okay, previous work experience, just making stuff up, 55% of people lie about that. Wow, skills, it seems like it's important, 43% of people lie about that. College degree, our equivalent, 41% lie. I mean, aren't people going to like follow up on that?
你们都在谷歌怎么伪造简历。所以这引出了这个问题。人们都在撒什么谎？根据Standout CV的调查，简历中最常见的八个谎言是：以前的工作经验，纯粹是编造的，55%的人在这方面撒谎。哇，技能，看起来很重要，43%的人在这方面撒谎。大学学位或同等学历，41%的人撒谎。我的意思是，难道人们不会去核实吗？
I don't know. I guess not. Personal details, location, name, et cetera, age, 39% lie about that. Okay. High school details, 39% lie, previous salary, ooh, 33% lie about that. I just want to say, if you're going to lie about anything, pad that previous salary. Exactly. What are you messing with all the other stuff for?
我不知道。我想不会吧。个人详细信息，住址、姓名等，年龄，39%的人在这方面撒谎。好吧。高中详细信息，39%的人撒谎，之前的薪水，噢，33%的人在这方面撒谎。我只想说，如果你非要撒谎，那就把之前的薪水写高点。没错。你干嘛要在其他事情上动脑筋呢？
You heard it here, lie about your previous salary. Yes. Job-specific software are equipment skills, 33% lie about that. Last on what people lie about, employer references, 21%. That seems like you're going to get caught. I know. This led me to the question, what professions are lied about the most when applying for these jobs?
你们都听到了，在之前的薪水上撒谎吧。是的。特定工作的软件或设备技能，33%的人在这方面撒谎。人们撒谎的最后一点是，雇主推荐信，21%。这看起来很容易被抓包。我知道。这让我产生了一个疑问，申请这些工作时，哪些职业最容易被撒谎？
The industry with the most employees lying on their resumes is manufacturing, with 72% of employees straying from the truth. The survey also found the next industry that had the most people lying on their resumes was the healthcare industry. Oh my gosh. 64%. And then the third most lied about profession was the arts at 63%, water skiing, special skill.
员工在简历上撒谎最多的行业是制造业，72%的员工偏离了事实。调查还发现，简历撒谎人数第二多的行业是医疗保健行业。天哪。64%。第三个最容易被撒谎的职业是艺术行业，占63%，滑水，特殊技能。
Exactly. Me. Be me. But there you have it. I found it fascinating. And Daryl would be part of this survey because he said he delivered over 2.5 billion units of inventory. Joe is not amused, by the way, by Daryl's padding of his resume.
没错。我。就是我。但事实就是这样。我觉得这很有趣。达里尔也会是这项调查的一部分，因为他说他交付了超过25亿单位的库存。顺便说一句，乔对达里尔简历上的水分并不买账。
She's not. And this is the time when Dwight decides to tell her he would also like to interview. And she said, fine, I'll interview you right now. Have you ever shot a gun in the office? Dwight says it's complicated and Joe says, yeah, but see, it's not. I love her. Such a good line. Love her.
她确实不买账。这时德怀特决定告诉她他也想参加面试。她说，好吧，我现在就面试你。你在办公室开过枪吗？德怀特说这很复杂，乔说，是啊，但你看，这并不复杂。我爱死她了。真是句好台词。爱她。
This next scene I'm going to call group goss in the break room. We had hot goss last week. This is group goss. Everyone is talking about Angela's engagement to the senator. Do they tell her he's gay or not? I googled whether or not you should tell your friend our coworker. True. This is only their coworker.
接下来的这一幕我称之为休息室里的集体八卦。我们上周有热门八卦。这是集体八卦。每个人都在谈论安吉拉和参议员的订婚。他们要不要告诉她他是同性恋？我谷歌了一下是否应该告诉你的朋友或同事。真的。这只是他们的同事。
Because I was going to say, I doubt Angela considers half of this room her friends. Maybe no one in this room. Every article says, mind your own business, do not tell your friend that you think their fiance is gay. It's not your business. It's not your business. Although years later down the road, they might turn to you and say, you knew this all along? Well, one of the articles I read said, if you have direct evidence, it can't be like
因为我本来想说，我怀疑安吉拉是否把这屋里的一半人当朋友。也许这屋里一个人都不算。每一篇文章都说，管好你自己的事，不要告诉你的朋友你觉得他们的未婚夫是同性恋。这不是你的事。这不是你的事。虽然多年以后，他们可能会转过头对你说，你一直都知道？嗯，我读过的一篇文章说，如果你有直接证据，不能仅仅是
if it's a hunch because, you know, you need like, I saw your fiance out with another person. That also just, it doesn't even matter the sexual orientation. If you saw someone's fiance out with another person romantically, you're going to want to tell them before they marry them. But this group does not have that evidence. No, they have a few likes on Ryan's Facebook photos at three in the morning and a hunch from Oscar. Yeah.
如果只是预感的话，因为，你知道，你需要像，我看到你的未婚夫和另一个人在一起。这甚至与性取向无关。如果你看到某人的未婚夫和另一个人浪漫地在一起，你肯定想在他们结婚前告诉他们。但这群人没有证据。不，他们只有凌晨三点在瑞安的Facebook照片上点的几个赞，以及奥斯卡的预感。是的。
Well, Phyllis says, you know, this might be her last chance at a family. And they ultimately decide not to tell her. At this point, Kelly is going to ask for a private meeting with Joe. She's going to kick Gabe out of the conference room. And this is when she tells Joe that Gabe is gross and that his behavior with Aaron was unprofessional and she thinks Joe should know. Throughout this scene, Joe is getting a text from Dwight. That's his resume one line at a time because of this old tech alert.
嗯，菲利斯说，你知道，这可能是她拥有家庭的最后机会了。他们最终决定不告诉她。此时，凯利要求与乔进行私人会谈。她要把盖博赶出会议室。就在这时，她告诉乔盖博很恶心，他对艾琳的行为很不专业，她认为乔应该知道。在这一幕中，乔一直在收到德怀特的短信。因为这个老式技术提醒，他的简历是一行一行发过来的。
She's roaming you guys. She's on a flip phone. This is costing her a ton of money. Yeah. So she screams at him, jackass, stop it. Next up, Creed is going to tell Jordan to get their biggest client on the phone. And Pam says, oh my gosh, just put them through to me. And Pam pretends to be the client.
她在漫游，伙计们。她用的是翻盖手机。这要花掉她一大笔钱。是的。所以她对他尖叫，混蛋，停下。接下来，克里德要让乔丹把他们最大的客户接通电话。帕姆说，噢天哪，直接转给我吧。帕姆假装是那个客户。
Hello. I mean, Jenna, I'm so sorry. All I could think about with all your characters and different clients in this episode was, I think Pam would make a fantastic mom detective. Oh, because of all my characters I could do. Yes. Lady following up on last week, my windowless building. Yeah.
喂。我的意思是，珍娜，我很抱歉。在这一集中，所有关于你的角色和不同客户的想法让我觉得，我觉得帕姆会成为一个出色的妈妈侦探。噢，因为我能扮演的所有角色。是的。女士，接着上周的话题，我的无窗建筑。是的。
I circled the building on my way home. Did you really? There's one window in the back on the second floor. One. That's it. A single window. What are they doing in there? It doesn't make any sense.
我回家路上绕着那栋楼转了一圈。你真的转了？二楼后面有一个窗户。一个。就这一个。那是一个单窗。他们在里面做什么？这根本说不通。
I mean, here's the other thing about the building. If you take a picture of it outside, it looks like there's glass. It looks like, oh, maybe that's like, maybe it is a window, right? It's like fragmented. It's artistic looking. But I know it's not a window because I watched them build it from the ground up and there is no window there. A fakie window.
我的意思是，关于那栋楼还有一点。如果你在外面给它拍照，看起来好像有玻璃。看起来像，噢，也许那是，也许那是个窗户，对吧？它看起来是碎片化的。看起来很有艺术感。但我知道那不是窗户，因为我看着他们从地基开始盖起来的，那里根本没有窗户。一个假窗户。
So they're doing fakie window and an otherwise windowless building with absolutely no signage of any kind on the building and one tiny, tiny window around the back on the second floor. What is it? I am perplexed. I just remembered a long time ago I got a gift of binoculars for bird watching. You're not going to see anything. It's a windowless building. But don't you want to, like, who goes in and out?
所以他们在一个本来没有窗户的建筑上做了个假窗户，建筑上没有任何标志，二楼后面只有一个小得可怜的窗户。那是什么？我困惑了。我刚想起很久以前我收到过一副观鸟用的望远镜。你什么也看不见。那是一栋无窗建筑。但你难道不想，比如，谁进进出出？
Nobody goes in and out. That's the thing. There's like maybe one or two. They have a whole parking lot, too, and you know how hard it is to get a parking lot in Los Angeles. You've got a whole parking lot and every once in a while you see a van. Oh, sketchy. What is it?
没人进进出出。这就是问题所在。可能有一两个人吧。他们还有一个完整的停车场，你知道在洛杉矶找个停车场有多难。他们有一个完整的停车场，偶尔你会看到一辆货车。噢，真可疑。那是什么？
It's so sketchy. I don't know. I had a mom detective update, but it's nowhere near as interesting as this windowless building with a parking lot and a van. Update. Well, you know those bird scooter things that people ride around? No. What?
太可疑了。我不知道。我有一个妈妈侦探的更新，但远没有这个带停车场和货车的无窗建筑有趣。更新。嗯，你知道人们骑的那种鸟牌滑板车吗？不。什么？
Jenna, the city scooters. Oh, sorry. Yeah. I thought you literally meant it was like a scooter to look at birds. It's called the bird scooter. BYRD. Okay. I would ride a scooter that was specially made to go look at birds.
珍娜，城市滑板车。噢，抱歉。是的。我以为你字面上是指那种用来观察鸟类的滑板车。它叫鸟牌滑板车。B-Y-R-D。好吧。我会骑那种专门用来观察鸟类的滑板车。
I thought that's what you were talking about. No. They're the scooters that people ride around. You have an app or something on your phone. I don't know how. Yeah. You unlock them. Okay.
我以为你在说那个。不。那是人们骑着到处跑的滑板车。你的手机上有个应用程序什么的。我不知道怎么弄。是的。你解锁它们。好吧。
And then when you're done with it, you just leave it on the sidewalk. It's super annoying and then people can't push their strollers down the street or use a wheelchair on the sidewalk. Guess what's been happening in my neighborhood? Are they leaving them on your sidewalk? They're just leaving them in people's lawns. In people's lawns? Yeah.
然后当你用完的时候，你就把它留在人行道上。这超级烦人，然后人们就没法推着婴儿车走在街上，或者在人行道上使用轮椅。猜猜我社区里发生了什么？他们把它们留在你的人行道上了吗？他们只是把它们留在人们的草坪上。在人们的草坪上？是的。
They're just over in people's lawns and my neighborhood is not having it. It's young people. It only happens on the weekend because I sound so old. Like I think this is my theory because like I went to bed, I turn off the lights, it's like 11 o'clock at night, and then I get up the next morning and there's a bird flopped over in the yard. A bird scooter. A bird scooter.
它们就丢在人们的草坪上，我的社区可受不了这个。是年轻人干的。这只发生在周末，因为我听起来太老了。就像这是我的理论，因为我上床睡觉，关掉灯，大概是晚上11点，然后第二天早上起来，院子里就倒着一只“鸟”。一只鸟牌滑板车。一只鸟牌滑板车。
Yes. Sorry. Not an actual bird. And I was like, when did that bird, you know, get flopped over in the yard? I feel like someone is coming home. A little tipsy on the scooter. We have two cases. We have two cases.
是的。抱歉。不是真的鸟。我就想，那只“鸟”是什么时候倒在院子里的？我觉得有人回家了。骑着滑板车有点醉醺醺的。我们有两个案子。我们有两个案子。
That's all I have to say. Who's flopping the birds in the yards? And what's in the windowless building? Next episode of Mom Detectives, sh** going down. You see why this is going to be a hit show because of these riveting plot lines. All right. Next up is the scene where Aaron is going to bring in Mr. Jacques Souvenir, the Frenchman. They talked with Rain about this scene.
我只想说这些。是谁把“鸟”丢在院子里的？无窗建筑里到底有什么？下一集《妈妈侦探》，好戏上演。你明白为什么这会成为热门节目了吧，因为这些引人入胜的情节线。好的。接下来是艾琳带雅克·苏文尼先生，那位法国人进来的场景。他们和雷恩谈过这个场景。
I guess all I have to say now here in the breakdown is that I love it. I'm pretty sure his name was Jacques Souvenir. Oh, I'm so sorry. You said it the way Joe says it. Yes. So sorry. You're right. He is French.
我想我现在在解析中要说的就是我喜欢它。我很确定他的名字叫雅克·苏文尼。噢，我很抱歉。你说的语气和乔说的一样。是的。很抱歉。你是对的。他是法国人。
After Dwight leaves the conference room, Joe's like, all right, who are the real contenders? What about Andy? And Gabe just goes off and she's like, you know what, Gabe, I think it's time to get you back to Florida. You got too close to the people here. We need to get you home. Well, this is a big plot point because it means we're going to say goodbye to Gabe for a little while.
德怀特离开会议室后，乔说，好吧，谁是真正的竞争者？安迪怎么样？盖博就发火了，她说，你知道吗，盖博，我觉得是时候让你回佛罗里达了。你和这里的人走得太近了。我们需要让你回家。嗯，这是一个重要的情节转折，因为这意味着我们要和盖博告别一段时间了。
Gabe is going to be back in season eight and this is reminding me. We need to reach out to Zach Woods and have him on this podcast. I know. I have a lot I need to speak with him about. Zach, I just want to hang out with you. That's kind of what this podcast is for. Yeah. Well, Jim is going to walk Joe to her car and she asked him, how did her friend, Nelly,
盖博会在第八季回来，这提醒了我。我们需要联系扎克·伍兹，让他上这个播客。我知道。我有很多话要和他聊。扎克，我只想和你待在一起。这大概就是这个播客的目的。是的。嗯，吉姆要送乔去她的车，她问他，她的朋友内莉在面试中表现如何？
do in the interview? Jim said, well, we didn't know that Nelly was your friend and Joe was like, that's a kind of classy move, right? Yeah. But Jim's like, you know, we still don't think she's a good fit. And then this is a surprise moment. Joe tells Jim, go ahead and give Dwight an interview. I like a little crazy.
吉姆说，嗯，我们不知道内莉是你的朋友，乔说，那是个挺高级的举动，对吧？是的。但吉姆说，你知道，我们还是觉得她不合适。然后这是一个惊喜时刻。乔告诉吉姆，去给德怀特面试吧。我喜欢有点疯狂的。
I can't believe she's going to give him another interview after everything. And then her trunk opens. Did you see how it opens onto Jim? Yeah. That bends out of the way. Up next is one of my favorite Oscar moments for the whole entire season seven. What is it? It is just one of those tiny throwaway moments, but it made me laugh so hard.
我不敢相信在发生这一切之后她还要给他面试。然后她的后备箱打开了。你看到它是怎么撞向吉姆的吗？是的。那弯曲着避开了。接下来是整个第七季中我最喜欢的奥斯卡时刻之一。是什么？那只是那些微小的、随意的时刻之一，但我笑得太厉害了。
I rewound the scene and watched it again. Oscar is going to walk up to front reception to drop off a package, a gray sock puppet with a red bow greets him. Oscar says, Erin, what are you doing? Erin says, I've been turned into a puppet. And Oscar goes, okay, and just walks away, doesn't entertain. The puppet doesn't stay around to find out why he's like, no, okay. I loved it so much.
我倒回去又看了一遍。奥斯卡走到前台去放一个包裹，一个戴着红蝴蝶结的灰色袜子木偶向他打招呼。奥斯卡说，艾琳，你在干什么？艾琳说，我变成了一个木偶。奥斯卡说，好吧，然后就走开了，没有理会。木偶没有留下来问他为什么，他说，不，好吧。我太喜欢了。
We got a fan question from Kristen S. in New Brunswick, Canada, who said, Kevin's talking head about the puppets is what I believe to be the most underrated comedy bit in the office. I laugh out loud every time my son plays it for me just to hear me laugh. Brian Baumgartner's earnest delivery is perfection. Well Kristen, I totally agreed with you and I felt like we should hear this talking head. It's just that I wish the puppets would talk more about the alphabet. Not for me, but if any kids are watching, A, B, and so forth, you know, M-N-L-O, P, F.
我们收到了来自加拿大新不伦瑞克省克里斯汀·S的粉丝提问，她说，凯文关于木偶的谈话头是我认为《办公室》中最被低估的喜剧片段。每次我儿子为了听我笑而播放它时，我都会大笑出声。布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳真诚的表演简直完美。嗯，克里斯汀，我完全同意你的看法，我觉得我们应该听听这个谈话头。只是我希望木偶能多谈谈字母表。不是为了我，但如果有孩子在看的话，A，B，以此类推，你知道，M-N-L-O，P，F。
Yes, this is the moment we find out that Kevin thinks M-N-L-O is a letter in the alphabet, which brought me to this, Jenna. His last name is Malone. He has an M, he has an L, an O, and an N in his name. Can he spell his name? It doesn't seem like it. Perhaps not. Well, the hand puppet is going to explain that she needs a date with the best salesman
是的，这就是我们发现凯文认为M-N-L-O是字母表中的一个字母的时刻，这让我想到了这一点，珍娜。他的姓是马龙（Malone）。他的名字里有M，有L，有O，还有N。他会拼写自己的名字吗？看起来不会。也许不会。嗯，手偶要解释说她需要和办公室里最好的销售员安迪·伯纳德约会。
in the office, Andy Bernard. Yeah, Andy walks over and he says he's flattered, but he doesn't think that they should date. I mean, I would just have to, that would be it. I would leave. I'm done working here by everybody. That's so embarrassing. I would not be able to come back from that. He has a talking head that is really a series of talking heads, I guess, right?
是的，安迪走过来，他说他很受宠若惊，但他认为他们不应该约会。我的意思是，我只会，那就算了。我会离开。我不在这儿工作了，再见大家。那太尴尬了。我无法从那件事中走出来。他有一个谈话头，实际上是一系列的谈话头，我想，对吧？
He gives a lot of reasons for why he doesn't think they should date, that, you know, Aaron's his best friend, but he just didn't feel it, or he's got a really weird thing about how like, sometimes you really want to like things, but you just can't seem to like mad men or football. And then he sort of says like, maybe he got over Aaron if there's like so many reasons. Well, he also said, let's not forget she chose Gabe over me, that would hurt. But then he ends with, well, actually, she's pretty great. I'm confused.
他给出了很多理由说明为什么他认为他们不应该约会，比如，你知道，艾琳是他最好的朋友，但他就是没感觉，或者他对某些事情有种奇怪的感觉，比如有时候你真的很想喜欢某些东西，但你就是没法喜欢《广告狂人》或橄榄球。然后他有点说，也许他能放下艾琳，如果理由这么多的话。嗯，他还说，别忘了她选择了盖博而不是我，那会很受伤。但最后他说，嗯，其实，她挺好的。我很困惑。
I think he is too. Next up, we get to meet the new bride, Zilla, in the office. I really loved doing this scene. Angela has only been engaged a few hours. You guys, like a few hours, like three hours, and she's already making big plans and telling people they're not going to be invited. She's like, Stanley, I won't be able to invite everyone to the wedding because we want to keep it to 350.
我想他也是。接下来，我们要见到办公室里的新准新娘，齐拉。我真的很喜欢拍这一幕。安吉拉订婚才几个小时。伙计们，才几个小时，大概三个小时，她就已经在制定宏大的计划，并告诉人们他们不会被邀请。她说，斯坦利，我没法邀请所有人参加婚礼，因为我们想控制在350人以内。
Stanley's like, I'll get over it. Yes. Angela's like, I mean, we just have to see how many senators and members of Congress want to attend before we can open it up, you know, to regular people. And then she says, Pam, you know how you and Jim did your ironic wedding? Do you still have the plans for the dream wedding that you couldn't afford? And Pam says, that was our dream wedding. And Angela says, Niagara Falls, pregnant.
斯坦利说，我会想开的。是的。安吉拉说，我的意思是，我们得先看看有多少参议员和国会议员想参加，然后才能向普通人开放。然后她说，帕姆，你知道你和吉姆是怎么举行那种讽刺婚礼的吗？你还有那些你们负担不起的梦幻婚礼的计划吗？帕姆说，那就是我们的梦幻婚礼。安吉拉说，尼亚加拉大瀑布，怀孕。
That was your dream. Pork medallions. Oh my gosh. She is going to be horrible to deal with. Pam gives a little look to Oscar. And he gives her a look back like Pam. And then she goes, very weighted. She says, Angela, I hope you have a very beautiful wedding.
那是你的梦想。猪肉奖章。噢天哪。和她打交道会很可怕。帕姆看了奥斯卡一眼。他回了她一个眼神，好像在说帕姆。然后她说，语气很沉重。她说，安吉拉，我希望你有一场非常美丽的婚礼。
That ain't what she really means. Well, let's take a break because when we come back, Kelly has joined the search committee and things are going to get a little dicey. We're back from break and before we keep breaking down this episode, Angela, I have something for you. What? You know, we haven't had a chance to talk about our live show in Vancouver that we did. We haven't talked about it on the pod.
那可不是她真正的意思。嗯，我们休息一下，因为回来后，凯利加入了搜索委员会，事情会变得有点棘手。我们休息回来了，在继续解析这一集之前，安吉拉，我有东西给你。什么？你知道，我们还没机会谈谈我们在温哥华做的现场演出。我们还没在播客上谈过。
It was so amazing. I mean, a lot of what was so amazing about it was just all of the really good best friend time that we had. I know I made a bunch of stories over at Office Ladies Pod. I saved it as a highlight, but what a fun time to just go explore Vancouver a little bit. Well, during the show, there was a moment that took us both by surprise. I was not surprised by it.
太棒了。我的意思是，它之所以如此精彩，很大程度上是因为我们度过了非常美好的闺蜜时光。我知道我在Office Ladies Pod上发了一堆故事。我把它存成了精选，但去温哥华探索一下真是太有趣了。嗯，在演出期间，有一个时刻让我们俩都感到惊讶。我对此并不惊讶。
You weren't? You know what I'm talking about. Yes. I remember I said, I said, listen, if we do this show in Texas, this moment's going to kill. I'm not so sure about Vancouver. Well during the show, we have a moment where we discuss Chunkett versus Chuckett. Yeah.
你没有？你知道我在说什么。是的。我记得我说过，我说，听着，如果我们去德克萨斯做这场演出，这个时刻肯定会火。我不确定温哥华会怎样。嗯，在演出期间，我们有一个讨论“Chunkett”还是“Chuckett”的时刻。是的。
And we asked the audience, almost 4,000 people in attendance, amazing crowd, lovely people. Do any of you say Chunkett? Not a single person. No one in Vancouver says Chunkett. And I was like, okay, okay. Well I told you earlier that I went to our general mail bag this week, Angela. And I found this letter and in honor of that Cricket's moment at our Vancouver live show, it was so funny.
我们问观众，现场有近4000人，很棒的观众，可爱的人们。你们有人说“Chunkett”吗？没有一个人。温哥华没人说“Chunkett”。我就想，好吧，好吧。嗯，我早些时候告诉你，我这周看了我们的通用邮件袋，安吉拉。我发现了这封信，为了纪念我们在温哥华现场演出时的那个“Cricket”时刻，太搞笑了。
I wanted to give you this gift. Okay. This is Angela Madeline from Utah, who says, I was just watching Modern Family. And on season three, episode nine, they say Chunkett. No. Yes. In fact, the title of the episode is Pumpkin Chunkin. What?
我想给你这个礼物。好吧。这是来自犹他州的安吉拉·马德琳，她说，我刚才在看《摩登家庭》。在第三季第九集，他们说了“Chunkett”。不。是的。事实上，那一集的标题就是《南瓜投掷》（Pumpkin Chunkin）。什么？
In the episode, Cameron is trying to prove to the rest of his family that he used a slingshot to fling a pumpkin across a football field. And in this episode, they all refer to this as chunking the pumpkin. Yes! Madeline said, I just thought Angela would be so grateful. And Angela, I recorded this audio clip for you. This is just one tiny moment from the episode where they repeatedly say Chunkett. I'm just saying maybe you take Pumpkin Chunkin out of the rotation.
在那一集中，卡梅隆试图向他的家人证明他用弹弓把一个南瓜扔过了橄榄球场。在这一集中，他们都把这称为“chunking the pumpkin”。是的！马德琳说，我只是觉得安吉拉会很感激。安吉拉，我为你录了这个音频片段。这只是那一集中他们反复说“Chunkett”的一小段。我只是说也许你可以把《南瓜投掷》从播放列表中删掉。
I guess you're right. Maybe I could just... Yeah, stick to the ones that really happen, because people love those. Excuse me, what? I'm just saying people laugh more at stories that are true. Pumpkin Chunkin is a true story. True-ish? No.
我想你是对的。也许我可以只……是的，坚持那些真正发生过的事情，因为人们喜欢那些。对不起，什么？我只是说人们对真实的故事笑得更多。《南瓜投掷》是个真实的故事。半真半假？不。
True. Really? The length of a football field through the sunroof of a car that was open in late November in Missouri. It was unseasonably warm. I'll explain. It's a fog rolling over the hell. And who's Cody, who you're close enough to chunk with but mysteriously only appears in
真的。真的吗？橄榄球场的长度，穿过11月下旬密苏里州开着的汽车天窗。那天天气异常温暖。我会解释的。那是笼罩在山上的雾。还有那个科迪是谁，你和他熟到可以一起投掷南瓜，但神秘地只出现在这个故事里？科迪在沙漠风暴行动中阵亡了。他是英雄。你知道，这一切来自一个从未投掷过南瓜的人？嗯，我也从未渴望过投掷。是的，这些都不是真的。给你，安吉拉。整整一集都在投掷！
this story? Cody was KIA in Desert Storm. He's a hero. You know, all this from someone who's never even chunked a Pumpkin? Well, I've never longed to Tonkin either. Yeah, these aren't real things. There you go, Angela. A whole episode of Chunking It!
马德琳，我要从心底里感谢你。你知道，我知道外面有人说“Chunkett”，但当4000人说“不”的时候，真是太神奇了。我确实想对温哥华Just For Laughs的所有人说声大大的感谢。你们太棒了。谢谢所有到场的人。不过，温哥华观众发生了一件事，我觉得很神奇，就是我问有没有人会说印尼语。
Madeline, I want to thank you from the bottom of my heart. You know, I know people say Chunkett out there somewhere, but it was pretty amazing when 4,000 people were like, nope. I do want to say a big thank you to everyone at Just For Laughs Vancouver. You guys were awesome. Thank you to everyone who came out. And one thing, though, that happened with the Vancouver audience, which I thought was amazing, is I asked if anyone could speak Indonesian.
有几个人会说印尼语。我太激动了，我向他们大喊，我们有了一个时刻。你知道，我们真的很兴奋能继续做更多的现场演出。我们不得不暂停了一小会儿，因为我在《贱女孩》音乐剧电影里得到了那个角色。但我们没关系按下暂停键，因为我们太为你能在电影里出演感到兴奋了。我迫不及待想分享，但我们其实不应该分享任何细节。好的。
And there were several people that could speak Indonesian. I was so thrilled, and I yelled out to them, and we had a moment. You know, we're really excited to keep doing more of these live shows. We had to put them on pause for a hot second because I got that part in the Mean Girls movie musical. But we are okay to hit the pause button because we are so excited for you to be in this movie. And I can't wait to share about it, but we're not really supposed to share any details. All right.
你得给我们透露点内幕，女士。好的。我会看看在未来的剧集中能分享什么。所以就像我们在休息前说的，凯利现在是搜索委员会的成员，因为盖博要回佛罗里达了。他们现在要面试的第一个人是德怀特。嗯，实际上德怀特要在他们面前面试德怀特。他做得非常好。
You've got to give us some nuggets, lady. All right. I'll see what I can share in a future episode. So like we said before we went to break, Kelly is now a member of the search committee because Gabe is heading back to Florida. The first person that they're going to interview now is Dwight. Well, actually Dwight is going to interview Dwight in front of them. And he did a really good job.
我的意思是，他算是说服了托比和凯利，他应该有机会。我们收到了来自加拿大不列颠哥伦比亚省的粉丝反馈，她说，我10岁，你们是我最喜欢的播客，我有一个连续性发现。噢天哪。当凯利、托比和吉姆在进行经理职位的面试时，凯利的指甲涂的是白色的。但当他们在办公区讨论是否应该让德怀特当经理时，她的指甲现在是绿色的。
I mean, he kind of convinced Toby and Kelly that he should have a shot. We got a fan catch from British Columbia, Canada, who says, I'm 10 years old and you're my favorite podcast by far, and I have a continuity catch. Oh my gosh. When Kelly, Toby, and Jim are conducting interviews for the manager position, Kelly's nails are painted white. But when they're in the bullpen discussing if Dwight should be made manager, her nails are now green.
噢，柠檬。这是一个非常好的发现。去10分35秒。整个会议室里只有一个镜头能真正看到她的指甲。所以这个发现是多么注重细节啊。是在10分35秒她交叉双臂的时候。但到了12分03秒，她站在办公区的德怀特身后，她的手放在Froggy 101贴纸旁边的文件柜上，她的指甲非常绿。真是个伟大的发现。嗯哼。
Oh, lemon. This is such a good catch. So go to 10 minutes, 35 seconds. There is only one shot in the entire conference room where you actually see her nails. So that is how detail oriented this catch is. It's at 10 minutes and 35 seconds when she crosses her arms. But then at 12 minutes and three seconds, she is standing behind Dwight in the bullpen and she has her hands on the file cabinet right by the Froggy 101 sticker and her nails
嗯，很快，吉姆意识到凯利接受了交易。她有同样的引语，关于……噢，那个从坟墓里伸出来抓住你脖子的手是你想要放在方向盘上的那只手？宾果。
are very green. What a great catch. Mm-hmm. Well, pretty quickly, Jim realizes that Kelly took the deal. She has the same quote, that quote about the... Oh, the hand that comes out of the grave and grips around your neck is the one you want on the steering wheel? Bingo.
对。所以吉姆想，你接受了交易。但托比也同意她的观点。吉姆想，现在发生了什么，然后菲利斯冲进会议室说，德怀特和凯利告诉她德怀特是经理，他们预先解雇了她。所以这将导致一个史诗般的办公区场景，非常长且复杂，每个角色都在这里或那里有一句台词。我绝对喜欢它。
Right. So Jim's like, you took the deal. But then Toby is also agreeing with her. Jim is like, what is happening now, then fill us storms into the conference room and says that Dwight and Kelly told her that Dwight is the manager and they prefired her. So this is going to lead to an epic bullpen scene that is very long and very complex and every character gets to have a line here or a line there. And I absolutely loved it.
我觉得这对我来说非常经典。是的。迈尔斯·麦克纳特在他的评论中也指出了这一点。谢谢你，迈尔斯。所以我感觉我们有点心有灵犀了。嗯，基本上整个办公区都要对他们认为谁应该成为经理发表意见。是的。
It felt very classic office to me. Yeah. Miles McNutt pointed it out in his review as well. Thank you, Miles. So I feel like we've got a little same brain thing happening. Well, basically the whole entire bullpen is going to weigh in on who they think should be the manager. Yeah.
吉姆失去了对房间的控制。很快就失去了控制。凯文说了一会儿。他很高兴，因为他吸引了所有人的注意，但他没什么可说的。他们把他赶走了。他们说，只有你有贡献时才能发言。瑞安说，我想要一个局外人，比如一个无家可归的人。这是一个非常美味的瑞安和帕姆时刻。
Jim has lost the room. Very quickly loses the room. Kevin talks for a bit. He's tickled because he has everyone's attention, but he has nothing to say. They shoe him off. They're like, you can only speak if you have something to contribute. And Ryan says, I want an outsider like a homeless person. This is a really delicious Ryan Pam moment.
我太喜欢这些了。帕姆说，一个无家可归的人？真的吗？不，我要你说出你认为我们新经理的最佳人选是一个无家可归的人。瑞安说，让我猜猜你想要谁，帕姆，瑞秋·雷，《观点》节目的女士们？嗯哼。是的。
I love these so much. Pam says, a homeless person? Really? No, I want you to say that you think the best person to be our new manager is a homeless person. And Ryan's like, let me guess who you want, Pam, Rachel Ray, the ladies of the view? Mm-hmm. Yeah.
然后瑞安有一个谈话头，他说他在上一任老板手下逃脱了所有惩罚，这对他也并不好。他想要指导和领导，但你知道，当他有心情被领导的时候。是的。现在。不。我们收到了来自俄亥俄州哥伦布市Aaron G的粉丝提问。我觉得这很有趣。
Then Ryan has a talking head where he says he got away with everything under the last boss and it wasn't good for him. He wants guidance and leadership, but you know, when he's in the mood to be led. Yeah. Now. No. We had a fan question from Aaron G in Columbus, Ohio. I found this very interesting.
嗯哼。Aaron说，是否有一条规则或合同协议规定史蒂夫·卡瑞尔离开后不能使用“迈克尔”这个名字？什么？我知道。Aaron说，除非我记错了，在第七季剩余的剧集中，直到第九季快结束，迈克尔的名字都没有被使用或提及。在这个谈话头中，瑞安说，我在上一任老板手下逃脱了所有惩罚，
Mm-hmm. Aaron said, was there a rule or contractual agreement that you could not use the name Michael after Steve Carell left? What? I know. Aaron said, unless I'm mistaken for the remainder of the episodes of season seven and up to almost the end of season nine, Michael's name is not used or referenced. And in this talking head, Ryan says, I got away with everything under the last boss,
我觉得这有点奇怪。在那之后，我开始注意，并注意到直到第九季没人再说过“迈克尔”这个名字。好吧。嗯，我绝对不认为那是故意的。事实上，我发现在删除的场景中，当他的名字被提到时，记得吗，吉姆和帕姆有一个联合谈话头，是在删除的场景里。是的。
which I thought was kind of odd. After that, I started paying attention and noticed that no one says the name Michael again until season nine. Okay. Well, I definitely don't think that was intentional. In fact, I have found in deleted scenes when his name was said, remember, Jim and Pam have a joint talking head that was in deleted scenes. Yeah.
当我们发现迈克尔领养了一只狗并给它取名叫“帕姆·比克斯利”。帕姆·比克斯利，那是一只比格犬。是的。所以我认为这太疯狂了。不过我会开始注意这一点。我也是。新追踪器。
When we find out that Michael adopted a dog and named it. Pam Beaksley. Pam Beaksley and it's a beagle. Yeah. So I think that is so crazy. I'm going to start paying attention to that though. Me too. New tracker.
嗯，梅雷迪思对下一任分公司经理有一个要求。她希望这个人聪明、专业、果断、那方面很强，而且四十多岁。吉姆说，嘿，嘿，嘿。然后她说，好吧。雇那个小阴茎的家伙。安迪插话了。他说，那对你有用吗，比如小到中等大小的阴茎？噢天哪。
Well, Meredith has a request for the next branch manager. She wants this person to be smart, professional, decisive, well-hung and in his forties. And Jim's like, hey, hey, hey. And then she's like, fine. Hire the guy with a small penis. Andy chimes in. He says, would that work for you like a small to moderate penis? Oh my gosh.
太搞笑了。太搞笑了。艾德的表演简直完美。太完美了。这就是盖博要离开的时候。抱歉。抱歉。这让我发笑，因为我在想象凯利拥抱他时的反应，那真是太搞笑了。
It was so funny. It was so funny. Ed's delivery on that is perfection. It's so perfect. This is when Gabe is going to leave. Sorry. Sorry. It makes me laugh because I'm imagining Kelly's reaction when she hugs him and it's just
她说，呃。他说，你没必要发出那种声音。她说，他比我想象的要瘦骨嶙峋得多。骨头多多了。当盖博离开时，我看着它，我想这群人等不及要吃蛋糕，为了任何理由开派对。他们简直就是，噢，什么？
so funny. She says, ew. And he goes, you don't have to make that noise. And she said, he was just so much bonier than I thought. There's so many more bones. When Gabe left as I was watching it, I thought this group of people can't wait to have a cake, a party for any reason. And they literally are like, oh, what?
你要走了？再见。我知道。而且你甚至不能用“这一切都发生在一天之内”作为借口。虽然也许你可以用“因为迈克尔不在”作为借口，因为即使有人要在三小时内离开，迈克尔也会找到办法让它变得有意义。对吧。
You're leaving? Bye. I know. And you can't even use the excuse that it all came down in one day. Although maybe you can use the excuse that it's because Michael wasn't there because even if someone's leaving in three hours, Michael's going to find a way to have it to do about it. Right.
所以事情变了，尤其是当他们是盖博的时候。吉姆再次建议达里尔。这时安吉拉决定加入对话。她说，嗯，让我说清楚。我只代表我自己，而不是我和参议员。我认为我们有一些很棒的候选人，这里有一场精彩而热烈的辩论。但让我们想想，托比说，不，不，不，我们对凯文做过这个，如果你没什么可说的。
So things have changed, especially when they're Gabe. Jim is going to suggest Daryl again. And this is when Angela decides to join the conversation. She says, well, let me be clear. I only speak for myself and not myself and the senator. I think we have some wonderful candidates and there's a great lively debate here. But let's think about, and Toby goes, no, no, no, we did this with Kevin, if you have nothing to say.
没错。别说话了。所以事情是这样的。当我们开始拍摄这一幕时，我和保罗以及我们的导演杰夫·布里茨谈过。我们有个想法，如果安吉拉已经把自己看作参议员的妻子，并且她在竞选活动中，那会很有趣。所以她在练习她的竞选演讲，但她决定就在这里试一试。一旦他们给了我那个提示，就太有趣了。
Exactly. Stop talking. So here's the thing. When we started filming this scene, I talked to Paul and our director, Jeff Blitz. And we had this idea that it would be really fun if Angela is already seeing herself as the senator's wife and she's like on the campaign trail. So she's practicing her campaign speeches, but she just decides to try it out right here. And once they gave me that note, it was so much fun.
我迫不及待想说出这些台词。作为演员，我喜欢当你得到一个好的提示时。是的。它为我改变了整个演讲。它打开了你的整个表演。女士，我们收到了一阵粉丝邮件。确实有一段时间没收到关于单一主题的邮件了。就是这个。
I couldn't wait to deliver these lines. I love as an actor when you get a good note. Yeah. It changed the whole speech for me. It opens up your whole performance. Lady, we got a fan mail flurry. It's really been a while since we've had such a flurry of mail on a single subject. And it was this.
为什么吉姆不担任经理？为什么他没有被考虑或面试这个职位？他不想。他不想当临时经理。但在办公室里的所有人中，除了达里尔，吉姆是我们另一个最清醒、最有资格的候选人。这有点让人费解。为什么他不想升职，获得更多的钱和更多的财务稳定性来养活他的
Why doesn't Jim step in as manager? Why was he not considered or interviewed for the position? He didn't want to be. He didn't want to be interim manager. But of everyone in the office, besides Darryl, Jim is our other most sober, most qualified candidate. It is sort of a why. Why doesn't he want a promotion with more money and more financial stability for his
家庭？为什么他不想那样？我同意这阵粉丝邮件。我不知道。我认为这个问题的诚实答案是，他们根本没打算让吉姆这个角色成为经理，因为拥有一个合格、清醒的经理对节目没有帮助。整个节目都依赖于有一个大家都不喜欢或者必须应付的分公司经理。
family? Why doesn't he want that? I agree with this fan mail flurry. I don't know. I think that the honest answer to this question is that they had no intention of making the character of Jim the manager because the show isn't served by having a qualified sober-minded manager. The whole show depends on having a branch manager that everyone doesn't like or has to
正确。嗯，他们现在得回到会议室去解决这个问题。你们有人注意到布莱恩饰演的凯文跟着他们回到会议室，然后他们把门关在他脸上吗？是的。布莱恩即兴发挥了那个。噢，那很有趣。
deal with. Correct. Well, they're going to have to go back to the conference room now to figure this out. Did any of you guys notice that Brian as Kevin follows them back in the conference room and they shut the door in his face? Yes. Brian improvised that. Oh, that's funny.
我完全记得他在那一刻这样做。我笑得前仰后合，因为我在想，他要去哪？嗯，我们要有一系列的谈话头。首先，菲利斯要让我们知道她接到了DNA办公室或领养机构的电话。你知道DNA办公室。你知道的。他们在车管所旁边。
I totally remember him doing it in the moment. And I was cracking up because I was like, where's he going? Well, we're going to have a series of talking heads. First of all, Phyllis is going to let us know that she got the call from the, I guess, DNA offices or adoption agency. You know the DNA offices. You know. They're by the DMV.
就像邮局、车管所、DNA办公室。DNA办公室。没错。嗯，他们打了电话。她和艾琳没有血缘关系。但她打算改天再告诉她。是的。是的。
It's like post office, DMV, the DNA office. DNA office. Exactly. Well, they called. And she and Erin are not related. But she's going to tell her another day. Yeah. Yeah.
她们一直很享受这个想法，也许菲利斯是她的妈妈。她还鼓励艾琳真正去追求安迪，艾琳用袜子木偶做到了，结果在所有人面前被拒绝了。所以也许这不是得到额外坏消息的最佳日子。好观点。这一集以来自各个候选人的一堆谈话头结束，关于，你知道，他们是否认为自己会得到这个经理职位。他们以“手指湖人”结束。
They've been enjoying, I guess, this idea that maybe Phyllis is her mom. And she also encouraged Erin to really go for Andy and Erin did it with a sock puppet and was told no in front of everyone. So maybe not the best day to get additional bad news. Good point. The episode ends with a bunch of talking heads from all the various candidates about, you know, whether or not they think they're going to get this job as the manager. They end with Finger Lakes guy.
最后见到了那个非常担心请前两周假去手指湖的家伙，他就是吉姆·凯瑞。布伦特·福雷斯特是负责联系吉姆·凯瑞经纪人的人。布伦特说吉姆·凯瑞非常热情地答应了。顺便说一句，吉姆·凯瑞凭借这个客串获得了第38届人民选择奖最受欢迎电视客串明星的提名。噢，为了“手指湖人”？为了“手指湖人”。
And finally meet the guy who was so worried about getting the first two weeks off work to go to the Finger Lakes and it's Jim Carrey. Brent Forrester was the person in charge of reaching out to Jim Carrey's reps. Brent said that Jim Carrey was an enthusiastic yes. And incidentally, Jim Carrey received a nomination for favorite TV guest star at the 38th People's Choice Awards for this cameo. Aw, for Finger Lakes guy? For Finger Lakes guy.
这一集能有这么多酷炫的客串明星真是太有趣了。重温这一集真的很有趣。嗯，我们有最后一个克里德作为分公司经理的时刻。他正在和他的第九大客户通话。是帕姆。是的。他认为第九大客户和第四大客户会相处得很好。现在他们必须互相交谈。
So fun that we got all of these cool guest stars for this episode. It really made it fun to rewatch. Well we have one final moment with Creed as branch manager. He's talking to his ninth biggest client. It's Pam. Yes. And he thinks the ninth biggest client and his fourth biggest client would get along. And now they have to all talk to each other.
是的。所以这一小段里我最喜欢的时刻之一是我即兴发挥的。这是当，你知道，他说，嘿乔丹，转接我的第四大客户。我把电话在键盘上滑过。那就是转接的声音。那是我即兴想出来的。我太喜欢了。
Yes. So one of my favorite moments in this little bit I improvised. Here's the moment when, you know, he says, hey Jordan, patch through my fourth biggest client. And I moved the phone across my keyboard. That was like, that's the patching through sound. That was a little bit I came up with. I loved it.
然后我得以表演对话的两边，这意味着，我很高兴。嗯，我不知道还有没有人注意到，但记得克里德是怎么说他会故意把人们的名字叫错，即使剧本里写得很正确吗？是的。嗯，在这一幕中，他叫乔丹为“乔丹娜”。噢，不错。
And then I got to perform both sides of the conversation, which was, I mean, it delighted me. Well, I don't know if anyone else caught it, but remember how Creed said he would intentionally say people's names wrong on purpose, even if they were written correctly in the script? Yes. Well, in this scene, he called Jordan. Jordana. Oh, nice.
然后我得同时表演对话的双方，这对我来说，我是说，这让我感到非常高兴。嗯，我不知道还有没有人注意到，但还记得克里德说过他会故意把别人的名字叫错吗，即使剧本上写的是对的？是的。嗯，在这一幕里，他管乔丹叫乔丹娜。哦，真不错。
Well, we should say that this is going to end Creed's stint as manager and will also be saying goodbye to Cody Horn, who played Jordan. She does not return in season eight, but a lot of new stuff does happen in season eight. And I cannot wait to break down the list. Oh, I can't wait. Before we get to season eight, we had a fun idea, you guys. We think it is time to break down a Keanu Reeves movie and we're going to start with speed.
嗯，我们应该说，这将结束克里德作为经理的任期，也将告别饰演乔丹的科迪·霍恩。她没有回归第八季，但第八季确实发生了很多新事情。我迫不及待地想把这份清单拆解开来。哦，我等不及了。在进入第八季之前，我们有一个有趣的想法，伙计们。我们认为现在是时候剖析一部基努·里维斯的电影了，我们将从《生死时速》开始。
Yes. A little palate cleanser between season seven and season eight. Next week we're breaking down speed. So tune in next week to hear us talk about Keanu Reeves and everything about that big old bus. And thank you guys so much for listening today. And a big thank you to Rainn Wilson, who came into the studio. Just what a special person.
是的。在第七季和第八季之间做一个小小的调剂。下周我们将剖析《生死时速》。所以下周请收听我们谈论基努·里维斯以及关于那辆大巴士的一切。非常感谢大家今天的收听。还要特别感谢来到演播室的雷恩·威尔森。他真是个特别的人。
Thank you, Rainn. We love you. Bye, you guys. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoke.
谢谢你，雷恩。我们爱你。再见，伙计们。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔担任执行制片人。我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的助理制片人是安斯利·布比科克。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。如需无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需Stitcher Premium的一个月免费试用，请使用代码Office。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。